people who are disgusted by the Spanish flag
it is today that decides what the government of spain does
yes I simply found it
why it has separated the flag from Spain
as it is very close and the European is this
this one is not so close
it looks very cool and spain is
we have set it aside a little bit
represents me much more by this flag than by this
here we have separatists who want to decide
which journalists can enter the press conference
what questions can you answer
and now they also want to decide
which are the official symbols I use or which I do not use?
no no here
to hold a press conference
in the congress of deputies
it should be mandatory to respect
and not to despise in such a way
the official symbols
incredible is that
people who are disgusted by the Spanish flag
it is today that decides what the government of spain does